okay so the topic of this video will be
the digestive system so let's get
started
so when you think about the digestive
system this is the body system that is
responsible for the digestion of food
and more importantly the absorption of
the nutrients you know you've probably
all heard the expression of you are what
you eat well this very much rings true
because the proteins the lipids the
nucleic acids the carbohydrates that we
create all come from the proteins and
the lipids and nucleic acids and the
carbohydrates that are in the food that
we eat so you literally are what you eat
you know our digestive system is over 30
feet in length if stretched out you know
in one straight line here and notice how
in the diagram there's a lot of twists
and turns and this is going to be really
important to provide additional surface
area in order to absorb the most
possible nutrients and when we get into
the notes on the small intestine I think
this will be even more evident
well the digestion process begins in the
mouth because that's where our salivary
glands are and so digestion even begins
before we take our first bite because
when we see foods and we know we're
about to start eating allow our salivary
glands start to release saliva there are
three major salivary glands the parotid
the parotid gland the submandibular
gland and the sublingual gland well in
general these glands will release in
secrete water mucus amylase amylase is
an enzyme that helps to break down much
of the starchy foods that we consume
starch in the foods we eat are converted
and broken down into glucose so the role
of our teeth is to help break the food
into smaller pieces and also to mix the
food with saliva so here's a small bite
of an apple and as we two
that Apple is broken into smaller pieces
and also mixed with the saliva that was
just previously mentioned and ultimately
your tongue will ultimately push the
food to your teeth and then ultimately
to the back of your throat the back area
of your throat is called the pharynx so
there we have the black dot in the
picture there's the ball of food that
we've just chewed and our tongue has
helped to push to the back of the throat
now this bowl of food that we're about
to swallow is what is called a bolus now
you may know that there's actually two
tubes in the back of our throat one of
them is called the trachea which leads
to our lungs and the other is called the
esophagus which leads to our stomach so
to prevent food from going down the
trachea and into the lungs there's a
flap of tissue called the epiglottis
here I just symbolized it with this
yellow line here so when we swallow the
food the epiglottis will close sealing
off the trachea this way the food bolus
the lump of food that ball of food can
then enter into the esophagus and head
down towards the stomach so when we move
into the esophagus area here the mossad
the esophagus is a muscular tube that
connects the back of the throat called
the pharynx to our stomach so this tube
that the bolus is traveling down this is
the esophagus and there's a series of
muscle contractions that will ultimately
push that food bolus from the pharynx
down to the stomach and this wave of
muscular contractions is what is called
in what is known as peristalsis so the
muscle the muscular peristaltic
contractions will push the bolus into
the stomach so now that the food bolus
has made its way into the stomach let's
head there next the stomach will release
acids and enzymes
- mechanically and chemically digest
that food bolus so mechanical digestion
is when muscles of the stomach will
twist and turn and mix that food with
various acids and enzymes the chemical
breakdown and chemical digestion comes
from the hydrochloric acid and the
various enzymes that are released from
your stomach you know one enzyme in
particular that is of importance is an
an enzyme by the name of pepsin which
helps to break down our proteins now if
you've ever wondered how come your
stomach doesn't digest itself well
that's because your stomach has a layer
of mucus that will coat the stomach
lining and every now and then the mucus
coating can be so thin and worn away
that the hydrochloric acid will actually
start to burn and break down and digest
the stomach itself and and this is what
is called a peptic ulcer which obviously
could be very painful but let's actually
focus on the digestion of our food so
the food bolus now that it's been mixed
and churned and and digested it's now a
soupy fluid of partially digested food
that goes by the name of time so time is
what is now sitting in our stomach and
will soon exit into the small intestines
and if we zoom out in you can see the
small intestine leads right into the red
excuse me if we zoom on in the stomach
leads right into the first part of the
small intestine known as the duodenum so
when we look at the small intestine and
there's our little soupy mixture called
chyme the kind will exit the stomach in
into the first part of the small
intestine known as the duodenum so
overall the small intestines are the
location where the newts where nutrients
will be absorbed into your bloodstream
so the first part is called the duodenum
I've also heard a printer
the duodenum so what happens is as the
as the acidic chyme exits stomach there
is a molecule by the name of bicarbonate
which is but basically baking soda that
is released by the duodenum to help to
neutralize the acids that are in the
kind this way it prevents the acids from
damaging the the small intestine and
notice how there's a pear-shaped green
object in the picture this is called our
gallbladder and it's releasing that
letter B's in the animation that stands
for bile the gallbladder will help to
release bile which will mix with the
kind to help break down any fats and
lipids that are mixed in with our the
food that we've eaten and notice how
there's also an object labeled the
pancreas that it's releasing letter e's
in my animation these are risk these are
symbolic of enzymes the pancreas will
release a variety of enzymes to break
down lipids and proteins and
carbohydrates and nucleic acids that
happen to be in the foods that we've
eaten and if we come back to our diagram
here of the small intestine you can see
the food sitting there in the first part
known as the duodenum let's recap where
we came from the back of the throat is
called the pharynx and the tube that
leads down is called the esophagus and
the esophagus leads into the stomach and
from the stomach the soupy mixture
called chyme enters the duodenum well
what happens next
next that soupy mixture called chyme
passes through the jejunum which is the
second part of the small intestines and
this is the location where most
nutrients are absorbed into the
bloodstream and so if we zoom out in
here we see the jejunum
and here we see a capillary with blood
traveling from left to right and here
are some of that CP time and as the time
passes through the jejunum nutrients are
absorbed from the chyme and into the
general circulation into the capillary
into the end of the bloodstream that
will take these nutrients all throughout
the body well there's a little secret
let's zoom on in a little closer and
when we zoom out into the cells of the
lining of the jejunum we see that they
have these little finger-like
projections on them these finger-like
projections are called villi these
microscopic villi are really wonderful
in increasing the surface area for
nutrients to be absorbed through the
bloodstream so when we add our time
nutrients there's more area now for
nutrients to be absorbed into the
bloodstream but there's another secret
that these villi hold let's zoom on in
to a closer look and when we zoom on
even closer we see here are two villi
villas
singular for villi the villi themselves
have tiny projections that are called
micro villi which add even more surface
area for the absorption of nutrients so
when we add the soupy mixture called
chyme as the kind passes through
nutrients from the time will pass into
the capillaries that surround these and
will lead the take the nutrients all
throughout the body and become part of
the general circulation of our blood so
then we come to the final part of the
small intestine known as the ileum and
the final part the ileum is where
various vitamins and any remaining
nutrients from the time will be absorbed
and then we pass into the large
intestine in the picture it's the green
area three main parts number one is
called the ascending colon ascending
means to come up and as you see our
soupy column is moving up on the right
side of our body notice there's also a
little appendage sticking out here at
the bottom of the ascending colon and
this is the appendix and this is a an
organ structure that was once thought to
be vestigial and really have no purpose
now it we think it hasn't very much a
reduced purpose compared to you know
other human ancestors but what we're
actually seeing is that the appendix is
somewhat important in in storing some of
the beneficial bacteria that survive
within our large intestines and notice
how now we have the what's called the
transverse colon which moves from the
right side of the body to the left side
of the body and then ultimately the part
on the left side the on our back of the
body is called the descending colon and
ultimately the soupy mixture chyme is
traveling through the through the three
parts of the large intestine and as it
does moose Chur is being extracted and
removed from this soupy mixture time now
the longer the soupy mixture came is in
the intestines more water will be
absorbed from it so if you ever have had
diarrhea what's happened is you've had
too little water removed from that soupy
time and when you went to the bathroom
the year your feces came out all runny
and watery well the kind of opposite of
that is if you're kind the soupy mixture
column is in your large intestines for
too long of a time too much water will
be absorbed and the feces will be very
solid and very hard to pass and that's
what constipation is
and so the large intestine is also the
home of many helpful bacteria that will
assist in digestion and also the release
of many vitamins that we need as part of
our as part of as part of our nutrition
and ultimately as the waste nears the
exit the waste is stored temporarily in
the rectum until we have a appropriate
convenient time where we can you know
make our way to a restroom and
ultimately then the feces will exit
through the anus which is a circular
ring of muscle that will open to allow
the feces out and hopefully into a
toilet and so as we round up this video
here pause the video and try to identify
the letters of this diagram I'm going to
go over the answers in three two one so
picture a is one of the salivary glands
at the back of the throat is picture B
which is the pharynx picture C is the
flap that covers the trachea known as
the epiglottis picture D would be the
esophagus picture E is the stomach
picture F is behind the stomach that's
the pancreas G would be the duodenum the
first part of the small intestine H
would be the jejunum which is the middle
part of the small intestines where most
nutrients are absorbed I would be the
end of the small intestines the ileum J
would be the ascending colon the first
part of the large intestines K would be
the transverse colon and then L would be
the descending colon colon M would be
the rectum which stores feces and then n
would be the anus the muscular ring
where feces is excreted and released
from so I hope you found this video
helpful out of this quick tour of the
digestive system thanks for watching